welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live every Friday and Tuesday except
when it's not Fred or Tuesday which does
happen occasionally at twitch.tv /a /li
productions today we have got an
absolute slammer of an episode before I
get into that I just want to say
congratulations EULA congratulation
because we as a matter of law just
slam-dunked man lost sown so first of
all I just want to give you a high I
mean the battle the battle is over but
the war is not quite over yet yeah not
quite over but the big battle that's a
big battle yeah and from here on
whatever happens we'll be okay I think
so yeah but anyway we'll get into all
that in a moment but first I want to
thank our sponsors who are quit audible
and Casper which I will love to talk
about more later but until then let's
talk about this lawsuit that we've just
won yeah so we were basically yesterday
morning I mean the verdict came in
through the judge yeah I was sleeping I
think was like 9 a.m. and ela wakes me
up and she says we won yeah and I've
I've had like dreams of this day to get
that text from the lawyer saying we won
yeah fine I've always loved I don't know
but it's weird when it finally happened
something you would like to think about
so much
seriously I fantasized about how we
would get that message what time of day
would it be
it's kind of nice in a way that it just
happened cuz I don't have any time to
think about it it was just like oh we
won didn't even know how to handle that
it's like what like I I didn't feel any
emotion so just like what but slowly
over the course of the day it was like
yeah we immediately started working on a
video explaining everything and then we
posted it in the evening and I think
only once we posted it I started to to
understand that it's real right to
celebrate yeah I feel the same way
because it was you know just the fact of
like getting out there and talk
think about it to our fans and getting
that off your chest it's like damn so
it's not quite the end well by the way I
just want to say the support and love we
got was absolutely bananas this twit
this tweet I put out that morning we won
the lawsuit here let me put it over here
this we won the lawsuit video coming
soon huge victory for fair use on
YouTube two hundred and eighty three
thousand likes whoa that is so crazy
that is so much that's like a Lifetime
Achievement Award kind of um is there
gonna be your paint wait forever yeah
well I don't know about that I don't I
don't necessarily like when people keep
pin tweets from like over like a month
ago sometimes people have pin tweets
from like an out from like a year ago
and it's like well dude cut let's move
on let's talk about some new [ __ ] so I
think a probably for like a week but man
oh man that was so cool and on reddit
basically the top three posts of reddit
like 60,000 plus votes was the video and
the announcement yeah it was great man
it felt good it felt good to get all
that support and love it's really nice
man it feels good because we we worked
and we battled behind the scenes so hard
and long on this and it's nice to share
the victory with with so many people
it's really hard to explain the process
it was such a nightmare so long okay
looking over all these like lawyer
documents and each motion is like 30
pages long and it was a lot I forgot to
say what we're actually doing today in
this episode because it's pretty great I
completely didn't talk about it so today
we're going to talk about a couple
things and after the break we have
Skippy the 37 year old virgin now he was
34 we made a video about when he made
that video and we have ryan johns amiss
they're calling in together basically i
want to know what ryan john's miss you
guys know the ultimate pick-up artist
the [ __ ] machine
the professional Soper that we made a
video about yeah he's a god so he's
gonna basically get and skip his brain
and give him some some advice how are we
gonna get Skippy's dick wet how are we
gonna get I want Skippy's dick in that
mason jar find the one you know that's
what I'm curious is he looking for the
one or is he just looking for the one
hole to get his big wet he's got to find
the one because it's gotta marry his
clock is ticking so 37 years old let's
just start by putting your dick in a
hole you know any hole holes optional
you know species optional I don't know
well we'll talk about we'll see this
really but anyway I just wanted to make
that clear that that is what we're doing
today
and that'll come up soon so I'm excited
for that conversation yeah back to the
lawsuit the it's but you guys can't
believe how many documents how
slow-moving the legal system is and on
one hand I understand why it's that way
because it's so important to be thorough
to get both sides the amount of time
they need for discovery for research for
writing really beautiful eloquent
arguments it's so serious but
everything's yeah it's a double-edged
sword yeah cuz on the other hand people
who are qualified to do that kind of
work
charge like one our highest rate
attorney was like 650 an hour an hour
that is that he charged you essentially
six thousand dollars for one day's full
of work which happened to us when we had
the depositions yeah that was like a
10-hour day so the deposition was
probably the most brutal part if I'm
being honest where I had to sit and a go
to conference room in Los Angeles for
this specific purpose was on like the
30th floor some huge godless LA
skyscraper I thought I I walked in there
and I lost the presence of God I was
like there's too many attorneys here
they block and God for my life and they
they originally wanted to have a
deposition for each one of us oh that
was so good
and thankfully our lawyers got me off
that was so good but poor Ethan had to
take all the questions so it was
basically a nine-hour day of brew at
seven hours on the record but it was
nine hours long of brutal relentless
interrogation that's basically designed
to exhaust you humiliate you throw you
off to make you tilt right so we've got
I go in there and we were expecting Matt
to be there too cuz and I was there too
yeah either came with me or oh Jesus
what was that again this this speaker
hopefully are okay anyway hopefully the
everyone listened just and get [ __ ]
their eardrums ruptured so yeah we're
expecting Matt to be there because he
can go to the deposition by law so I was
expecting this [ __ ] eating grin of Matt
parkouring up the side of the building
to come [ __ ] stare me down the whole
time right sulfur yeah he didn't he
didn't end up showing up but just
sitting there with Uncle Fester alone
his lawyers that was our nickname for
him was brutal enough oh my god and it
was like seven hours of justice for sure
it's just straight questioning no brakes
and like you when they say that the
point of it is to exhaust you so you
lose track and all that it's true that
really happened oh yes definitely a
totally that's the technique I mean
that's got it works good strategy so
they sit you down the first five hours
they just they just ask you [ __ ] to
exhaust you and you're using all your
mental capacity to answer these
questions and you think you're being
really slick and you're answering
everything perfectly but around five
hours comes around you don't realize how
mentally exhausted you can actually get
to the point where I wasn't able to
actually even like compute and there are
certain times like when he had lines of
questioning and I wasn't I couldn't
understand what he was getting at like
cuz you know he's trying to get to some
right it was all just always like a
point at the end to get you yeah because
he'll ask you like a question like our -
like do you think this is fair use and
I'd be like yeah sure and then six hours
later he'll be like
you said that was fair use then how do
you justify your answer now barring this
video clip and you're like oh my god do
that you know
it's stuff like that yeah but actually
Ethan did really good it really did it
was stuff just watching seriously and
you handled really good so they were
going to pose ela to the next day but
our lawyer or anyway there was there was
basically well the thing is you have to
pay it's expensive
it cost us the one day to pose Matt like
$20,000 I'm estimating but because you
have one attorney there who's present
taking the deposition you have one
listening you have two you have all the
preparation because they have to prepare
yes you they bring you in they coach you
for the deposition and then you you pay
someone to document it there's a
transcriber there there's somebody
videotaping it it's great so that one
day is actually probably the most heavy
day of the whole thing one of them so I
think you know well I remember his
lawyer was like am I gonna get anything
useful out of ela and our attorneys was
like no problem really
yeah so whatever but there was one
highlight at that deposition which was
like um he asked me like what did you
mean by by this and I said something
like or no anyway he asked me to find
what a meme is yeah I think maybe what
was the context of maybe something what
did that mean I was like can you define
what a meme is and I said something like
I've been waiting all my life and we
asked this on the record how do you
define what a meme is to this attorney
he's trying to [ __ ] your life up well
take a look in the mirror Uncle Fester
give her to the Adams family so anyway
let's see well it's all behind us now
but like the amount of paperwork like
how many motions were there there was um
first there was the summary for judgment
on the plead
things that we got denied right yes so
you do a summary judgment on the
pleadings and then they do a counter
summary these are all like 30 page
documents and then you do a counter to
their counter and then they do it or
something they you do a counter to your
account seriously every time I thought
we were done and then it's like oh they
just replied yes you need to reply to
their reply so then the judge denied our
our pleadings which was like the first
attempt to get it thrown out and frankly
I mean she did handle the case very well
and this is another thing of like why
this legal system is great and [ __ ] up
both in one because she the judges are
always worried about being overturned
and Appeals and so when a judge makes a
ruling on pleadings it makes it more
likely that it gets overturned on
appeals and so in an effort to be as
thorough as possible which is her job
and what sadly ends up costing us like
fifty thousand dollars or more it's
[ __ ] up that you have to decide those
two things is not necessarily anyone's
fault it's just the fact that lawyers
cost so much money so she said no to our
pleadings and when the pleadings I don't
know if you know what you're talking
about but we basically tried to end it
right there you know and say there's no
doubt that this is fair use let just
make a call now and she denied it
yeah basically right so then we're like
okay so now we have to go to summary
motion for summary judgment which is
basically the next level where years
make a petition to the judge to say with
the facts presented to you now no
reasonable juror would ever come to any
decision except that this should be
thrown out yeah and then they make the
opposing case so there was you know we
made our motion for summary judgment
they made their own motion for summary
judgment we countered each other's
motions for summary judgment there was a
reply to the counter for most Sheree
summary judgment for your replies each
other it's crazy and these are all
thirty you know Word documents and were
so I don't know how most people hands
are their lawsuits but me and ela were
personally extremely involved for being
you know I mean we I didn't see any
other possibility I've learned in life
that you can never completely trust
someone else
even if it's a doctor or your content or
your lawyer you know knowing is God and
everyone makes mistakes
absolutely so you always want to kind of
overlook everything especially if
something is important is yes especially
in this case so we read every single one
of those documents many times over and
have like lengthy conversations with our
lawyers about different ways to approach
the arguments and by the way our lawyers
are brilliant were brilliant the guys at
Fox raw chilled who and I want to make
clear that we won because of them and
not because of our previous attorneys I
don't want people I want people to know
where the credits due on this one it was
because of our new attorneys that one
this one that's what we hired them and
so they're brilliant but we went over
everything and it was like being having
a juggle that while actually making
doing our normal thing was like having a
freaking part-time job yeah and even
like with every motion you think we got
demotion we're done and then you'll get
an email from the lawyer like okay now
we need to write your declaration that
goes with the motion and that's another
three page thing that you didn't even
know about it yes and it's just
never-ending
I remember they sent me the transcript
of a seven hour long deposition on the
record and they says read over this
whole thing and market for heirs it was
like 400 pages I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
this is moby dick and justice boring
anyway so basically where we're at now
is that we won we won and the way that
the court works is that matt has the
option to appeal that option is
available to him and appeal is basically
if he decides to appeal it goes to a
higher court and they have to re argue
the case based on all the evidence and
the same arguments that was already set
forth the good thing is that the judge
made an extremely thorough examination
she made a go to summary judgment she
took her time she made an extremely
informed polished opinion
and she let Matt do all he put in all
his claims whatever you wanted to claim
she was like okay we'll allow it it
happened a couple of times where him and
his lawyer wanted to amend the complaint
because I mentioned I farted his name
like I heard him fart in the newest
video it sounded like Matt awesome dad
the complaint like the video where we
the video titled we're still being sued
the one where I cry after that video
they wanted to add something to the
lawsuit right what was it I don't
remember something about how we're
spending a narrative of being the victim
like something just obscene yeah
irrelevant and our lawyers were like
most likely she's not going to allow it
but just let you know that there's a
chance just that because she's being
thorough and she did allow it and it
made me nervous because our lawyers
all-time are being like well she's just
being thorough but I haven't heard [ __ ]
from her she's taking forever and I'm
like dude I don't know what's in her
heart right now yeah but it turned out
that is what it was because her opinion
was a strong powerful rebuke of Matt
because quintessential my friends made
the fun quintessential representing the
most perfect or typical example of
quality or class what a great word oh my
god a matter of law like she brought
down the gavel on this one so he has the
right to appeal but his chances are
looking pretty slim on that and I've
always suspected that Matt was never
paying for his lawsuit because as we
actually know from the deposition that's
public he is in fact a pizza delivery
boy he's not there's no way that he's
paying those bills in my opinion no I
mean it's possible but what I suspect
more likely is that um it's a
contingency basically his lawyer is like
I'll take this case on a contingency
that if we actually win money I get
probably almost all of it and Matt's
like yeah I just want to torture him
that's what I you know I'm guessing or
Matt just wanted his pervert perverted
people do when they don't have my
maybe they split it 50/50 you know it's
a contingency yeah the thing is like
usually an attorney would never take a
case like this on contingency but I
think because in the beginning they were
trying to shake us down for $4,000 and I
think his attorney saw it as a easy
quick cash out maybe more cash so it's
by going off there other people right
that's why we initially put our foot
down because I'm like what's to stop
this guy from Africa stun for 4,000
going to everyone else who's ever made a
reaction video and demanding money with
us as a legal precedent and so and then
the other thing is like there's ethics
to being a lawyer so once this actually
goes to the lawsuit goes he can't be
like we'll see you Matt he's obligated
to represent him but now that we're at
this point of Appeal I don't know if Tim
is still obligated to represent him he
doesn't have the money if you can't find
an attorney to take it on concision see
then that's it he can choose to
represent himself which would be a
[ __ ] riot I can't imagine what those
legal arguments will look like written
by Matt and so on so there's that aspect
and then the other aspect is we now are
at a crossroad where we can decide to
counter sue him for legal fees yeah a
lot of people think oh you won so you
automatically gonna get your lawyer fees
back that's not the case no
unfortunately you have to sue for that
which is basically getting involved into
more whole new process all new prices
probably months I don't know how long a
year I think our our lawyers estimated
it would cost between 20 and 50 thousand
dollars to sue him for damages or for
attorney fees here's the thing
assuming Matt's broke which I assume he
is so we would never actually get any
money from him we would probably
bankrupt him and we would definitely it
would set a legal precedent a powerful
one if the judge grants us attorney fees
it is a strong powerful deterrent to
anyone else who's thinking of doing what
he did because now you're really
standing a real possibility of being
liable for the
most of the [ __ ] but I think regardless
of what we're gonna choose to do we
don't know yet yeah I think it the
president has already been made I think
I mean it helps it does add weight it
helps but I feel like the majority we
did in fact that we why was the biggest
thing we did what we we set out to do
mm-hmm which is so crazy said then and
then like basically what's pretty much
par for the course is when this happens
usually the winning party will trade so
they'll say if you don't appeal we won't
sue you so that's the third option which
is pretty normal as I understand it from
our attorneys it's like the recommended
way yeah because it's just like just end
this [ __ ] just end it right but you know
but anyway so that that's pretty much
where we are now so it's like as we said
the battle is over but the war is not
over yet but hopefully you know this was
a huge victory and I'm just so [ __ ]
stoked to actually see a legal precedent
written down in the law books in favor
of reaction videos mm-hmm and not even
that just Internet content 4.com comment
and criticism yeah she said that our
video was like something you'd see in
any video what she's video analytics
class or across the country
quintessential mm-hmm comment and
criticism I mean the the distinction she
made is pretty clear in my mind because
and and she was so good in doing this
she said and for clarity not all
reaction videos are fair use when should
we agree we've always agreed with a of
course I hate these these people are
stealing content as much as I hate the
people who are removing videos
erroneously and illegally right so she
says if you're watching a video like a
viewing party if you're just sitting
there watching and not cutting it up
that's probably not fair use but she
made the special distinction for what we
do which is cutting it up pausing it
offering comments and criticism
throughout that seems like strongly and
likely
to be fair use and what I'm hoping and
the result of that is that YouTube and
other you know websites online can use
this legal precedent to inform the
decisions they make when they get DMCA
complaints so next time somebody files a
DMCA complaint for for reaction video
YouTube has the legal precedent to say
no due to the Court's prior rulings this
is fair use because 90% of the time
especially on YouTube when people file
those takedowns it's always because they
just don't like what you said about them
they don't even know about fair use or
the law or anything from our experience
that's what we've always had to deal
with yeah exactly and so now YouTube can
step in and say no here's a meme that I
love out of this whole thing here's a
this is a joke it's not actually from
the depositions Crysta transcript but
somebody made a goof on you know where
it is wait it is yeah the witness yes so
I did say that and mr. Berger you said
well I'm going to like this video that
was badass right yes
and then ela said yeah yes yeah it was
classic yeah this is from the deposition
that's what we're talking about
that's [ __ ] that's good [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah that's good what else we got
here the quintessential oh yeah this was
so funny basically right the day our
video posted this is Google search terms
for quintessential look at that spike
dude quintessential a meme the judge
brought that back into the lexicon wend
essential my friends is on the register
so the other thing that that like
cracked me up basically this was all
over the media all over the news BBC
News BBC news beat Gizmodo Kotaku PC
games TechCrunch tube filter I mean
everybody's talking about this [ __ ]
right
and really nice really supportive but
there was one that that stood out to me
and I was like wait what what am i
reading
Gizmodo Gizmodo look at the title of
their article popular pickup artist
comedian loses huge lawsuits against
youtubers that mocked him I mean just as
titles go i can pick a large that
popular pickup artist comedian it almost
sounds like it's like you gotta read it
a few times to make sure you heard it
right yeah it's a real underdog story
but here's about anyway the title here
you go listen to this basically they're
going to talk about how great it is for
fair use and stuff but listen how they
how they close this out after basically
talking about it now was a good time to
point out that the couple behind h3h3
channel aren't necessarily angels they
racked up millions of YouTube
subscribers making fun of other
youtubers and generally stirring up [ __ ]
this is written by a fourteen-year-old
which is written by Matt Haas this is
the editor of Gizmodo is Matt Hoss
they're here listen to this [ __ ] and in
terms of subscriber base the h3 couple
certainly comes off as a big bully bully
this is a serious website
Gizmodo maybe found a new job stepped up
kids moto I think they're butthurt I
think they think that we're like alright
extremists because we made fun of xarna
great thank you
let's see um comes out yeah we're big
bullies because we have won 4.6 million
subscribers while Matt only has 170,000
yeah that's a good comparison
considering he's the one who [ __ ]
sued us
I'm a big bully I'm defending myself
against a frivolous lawsuit you [ __ ]
idiots which we won so we're not even
that's what that's what bothers me about
the title this popular comedian pickup
artists lost a huge lawsuit against a
channel that mocked him it may it points
us out as like um I like how we brought
it on ourselves or something when
whenever people hear about the lawsuit
and then they
go and watch the actual video we made
about him they're like wow guys were so
nice to him what the [ __ ] yeah that's
the initial reaction over this how did
you say we were bullies were big bullies
with the wrong but they're strong
following the h3h3 couple also raised
over a hundred thousand and crowdfunding
for their defense even big bullies enjoy
the benefits of the First Amendment
though you need to you who is giving
editing jobs at Gizmodo to [ __ ]
middle schoolers they're starting [ __ ]
they'd like to start sharing with people
at the end of the day you can chalk all
this up to youtube drama going I or L
what a dick with trash article anyway so
this brings me to my next question which
I'm kinda I don't think it would ever
happen right but like having Matt Hoss
on the podcast would you ever want to do
that because I already knows my answer
yeah which is never in all caps right
all caps I think it would be interesting
but I mean I don't sit I'm not sure that
I don't think Matt would ever come on
because he's too but hurt but I think it
would be interesting just to confront
him and I want to hear his his deluded
excuses for why he's protecting users
rights or whatever he says I've got a
caller on the line let's see what they
have to say about it there we go our
first never callin all right how do I do
this
he's muted how do I do this Dan I can't
hear you yet I just didn't he might hurt
himself muted cuz he was on standby for
a while this is already disaster cannot
drum unmute yourself oh there you go
hey hey hey I got you I got you what's
up dude hey how are you did so what do
you think should Matt auspey on the
podcast was like hell no definitely not
but then it like maybe like a year or
two from now
and see maybe having a mom like after
like kind of Augusta settled I kind of
agree with that maybe they let the
tension settle a little bit get the
because I think Matt is such a
hot-headed arrogant kind of guy like
he's clearly so stubborn that he follows
through to the end
maybe it'll be a little more reasonable
then but I think I'd also rather him
just disappear into obscurity by then
what I I'm always waiting for new Matt
Hoss content as I said in our original
video anyway thanks for the call dude
appreciate you god bless you thinks
thanks cool how'd that go how was our
first Colin not mad that's great thanks
good I appreciate that let's do we have
anyone else okay
good job guys we handled that pretty
good thanks for the Colin Doug you see
we're [ __ ] professionals here do it I
dab on you haters actually interestingly
the top post on ima 8i AMA on reddit
right now is believe it or not I am a
request Matt Haas you know that I think
would be awesome
I'd love that I want to hear him talk
yeah just I want to hear him you know
justify himself which he's in Cape the
only thing he's done is make a youtube
video saying like the truth will come
out I'm high level I'm playing 3d chess
and so I'll talk about it once I've won
this case because there's so much more
this video is so ridiculous that he made
I think his master plan the whole time
was he was like I'm gonna make these
vlogs these videos and collect all the
hate comments to show as proof that I've
been irreparably damaged because once
that we actually work done with all the
motions and stuff he disappeared and
stopped making videos yeah I'd like to
hear what he has to say
either way unbelievable I'd love to see
that the fact that we're oh we're done
with this for now
pretty much I mean yeah we just have a
couple little small me Marino's so
anyway that's pretty much it for the
lawsuit so thank you everyone for your
support thanks for joining us on this
ride I mean it was an honor to be able
to lead the charge in a way on this one
I mean so cool you guys made it possible
I mean you guys enabled us to be able to
do that I don't know that we could have
done it on our own yeah I don't know
there's no way so it was a victory for
all of us I'm just so relieved it's been
a it's been crazy
now this next story is a juice City I'm
telling you turns out you remember we
were petitioning to the mayor of LA to
Daddy up on Jake Paul and it turns out
he did daddy up on Jake Paul because it
turns out that yesterday or was it today
I'm not sure on the day maybe yesterday
that the City of LA made some kind of
official decree that bars
Jake Paul for anyone from Team ten from
vlogging or filming in their home yeah
which is the main staging point the main
setting of all their vlogs he has a
vlogging ban and threatened what six
months prison time if he films in his
house it's it's pretty real
that is insane dude that is so crazy
because the other part I didn't know
that like prison time could be on the
line yeah I guess it's a misdemeanor and
they've been charged with all kinds of
like public nuisance things so the city
straight up was like you can't film
there anymore you're making it
intolerable
and the crazy thing is that because he's
become so high-profile they need permits
to film outside but because of the
nature of their content they make vlogs
that film everywhere they all be that's
just literally impossible I think they
may have to move out of LA that's the
only solution and it comes back to Mir
actually listen cuz we're like yo kick
Jake out of LA and he kind of is doing
this by saying you can't film in your
house and you need a permit to film
outside
you can see here in his latest vlog when
Nick Crompton who of who hails from the
City of England
it breaks it to him live in his vlog
watch this [ __ ] so good guys you can't
dab the heat out this time
turns out you were the ones that got
nabbed on Jack's film ask the question
what happens if the haters dab back
right now you get an answer that back
hard and fast and furious pretty funny
but actually no this is gonna be pretty
interesting to follow yeah I mean
there's some there an actual deep [ __ ]
here what do you what do you think about
that the idea of not being able to film
in her own house is kind of that's
pretty was American I thought that maybe
it's because they don't own the house so
I was thinking oh if they go and buy a
house maybe Daniel would be fine and
dick and that would solve it but Dan
told us that no that's just the law in
LA you need a permit so but I think this
was a court order specifically against
them there so yeah maybe you may
actually be right in that if they just
move to a more secluded place where
they're not disturbing their neighbors
then they may be able to film but until
then because there's still the team ten
house and when we talked to Jake he was
saying that they were having a lot of
trouble finding a new place because
everybody knows that they're just gonna
trash it and burn garbage and [ __ ]
anyway pretty fascinating family have
fun move out of Italy
seriously were they gonna go Las Vegas
that desert Utah somehow there's
youtubers in Utah it's the home of
Skippy Mormons anyway another thing that
went down before we get into the Skippy
Rian Johnson's conversation the trending
page I complained about it in our last
episode and listen I I kind of need to
rally on this point because our new
video has four million views over four
million views in 24 hours it is about us
law it is about copyright issues fair
use on YouTube every possible person we
know on the internet was talking about
it and not just that but publications
online publications and whenever you ask
YouTube how is the trending page decided
they say it's an aggregate of voix blogs
and stuff around the internet so this
video couldn't be any more possibly
trending in in theory and sure enough
you know it's trending in Canada in
Australia in Germany and Sweden
essentially our biggest markets besides
the United States the United States it
makes up 50% of our audience and somehow
this video is not trending in the USA
and then once we started complaining
about it on Twitter they trended the
reupload of the original reaction but
not the video about us winning the loss
of a [ __ ]
I went on Twitter and I started bitching
and tagging Team YouTube this morning
and then when we come back from doing
voiceover for payday then I'm getting
tweets Philly d3 to me and they're like
they trended you're bold guy reupload Y
Darwin why would they [ __ ] with me
they trended the bald guy reupload which
is like a two-year-old video now it's my
friend 3 on trending it's got no context
at all it's just an old shitty video I
mean essentially the audio is bad the
visual is bad there's no context at all
why would they trend that video and not
the lawsuit 1 I have no idea and it's
just it's just strange really it's
strange my biggest problem with it is
and you're I mean our biggest problem
with it is how they're not transparent
about what's happening there like at
least if it's gonna be a list that is
curated but by someone at least
presented that way yeah just yeah I
agree
but even Isis top creators on on YouTube
when we asked them how it works there
won't say that they just say blogs blogs
links from blogs just when a video goes
viral on other platforms but like so I
was thinking like and in this specific
video when we made it I was like no
cursing no adult stuff because I want to
I kind of want to see this is gonna
trend so we didn't curse in it this is
what I put on Twitter no cursing no
adult content relevant to US law huge
victory for fair use on YouTube and
YouTube meanwhile it's like let's trend
another Casey Neistat video I mean no
offense to Casey it's not his fault they
can't read about it's like dude what are
you doing it's so transparent to
everybody and in a way it's like feel
like Casey gets a lot of hate at at this
point for YouTube trending him so much
it's like a meme now it's becoming a bad
look for him there literally he is on
trending right now when our lawsuit
video wasn't him and like an ad for
tonight's show trending is essentially
just I have this whole conspiracy theory
like I was watching Jimmy Fallon last
night and they had the king of random on
mm-hmm I think that they made a backroom
deal where they're like will promote
youtubers on your platform and
trend your tonight shows and in a way to
let cross-promote and I mean I think
it's a great idea because you get more
people from traditional TV and the
YouTube ecosystem which in turn helps
all of us so in theory I think that's a
great idea but you gotta balance it they
can do whatever they want just be
transparent about it that's my biggest
creek with YouTube like just be honest
and I'm fine anyone although it is a
great little distal guy that they
trended that video dude I was so happy
with that play to re-upload it mm-hmm I
remember talking to our attorney and
we're talking about like theoretically
if we won we could do anything with that
video and we're like wait could we just
reapplied it and he's like yeah of
course you won it's your property it's
fair use by a matter of law and we're
like oh my god we have to reload it on
h3 it's so beautiful
alright alright so we can I just want to
see if anyone's in the discord no no
okay so we have Ryan Jones and Miss and
Skippy on standby coming up next we're
gonna hop on the phone with both of them
I'm actually really excited this is
gonna be fun I love both these guys but
first let me let me quickly thank our
sponsors before we get into that first
and foremost we've got quit okay do we
have a quick toothbrush this is probably
my favorite toothbrush of all time I'm I
am obsessed with oral hygiene either
will tell you that I brush my teeth like
10-minute sessions no no you will buy
slick a whole episode of some show
that's like 40 minutes long I feel like
that's I sometimes I feel like it's
gotta be bad for me cuz sometimes my
mouth gets no because every time we go
to the dentist there's nothing wrong
with Ethan I mean it's good for my teeth
he lives about hurt every time there's
something with me I mean you just seem
like you're pretty unlucky because you
floss and brush every day at least twice
a day but I floss every night yeah and
every time we go the dentist they're
like yeah they're like Ethan why do you
bother coming here ela you're
neela we need to change all your teeth
we need to give you ten root canals I
don't know what I don't know what it is
it's weird how some people I guess it is
something like um some people have like
deeper crevices in their teeth [ __ ] like
that yes yeah I do have that so anyway
I'm always on the search for a good
toothbrush because when you brush for
ten minutes if it's not perfectly soft
that [ __ ] will destroy your mouth and
not only is this the something one of
the softest Brussels I found it's got a
great even brush and it's got this timer
you turn on the vibrating you hear that
please more than just your mouth I
wonder if they like that hey they came
back yeah it's a sex toy it's more than
a toothbrush it's got more than one
purpose you turn on the vibrating and it
basically times your brush to make sure
you brush enough and it times out three
minutes of brushing time and I promised
you when you finish with this your mouth
is gonna be sparkly squeaky clean so to
get your quip and if you support the
show go right now to get quick comm
slash h3 and you'll get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's this part here
basically you just changed the top
that's your first refill pack free at
get quick calm slash h3 that's get gtq
you IP comm / h3 thank you so much to
quit
next up audible you guys all know and
love audible I love audible makes the
most mundane tasks a joy audible is the
largest source of online audiobooks
they've got at all guys it'll you know
if you're exercising if you're playing
video games you're taking a drive you
want to listen to a wonderful enriching
story go to audible and see what's good
bye II actually audible surprised me
with how much I actually enjoy this
service the narration is always really
good yeah they've got some celebs today
they're bringing the celebs I have
anybody
what book would I narrate do you think
some weight loss Plus that would be my
dream to narrate my own Fupa la spoke
for audible guys if you go to
audible.com slash h3 podcast you will
get a free audiobook with a 30-day free
trial now here's what I'm gonna
recommend you listen to Game of Thrones
Song of Ice and Fire book number one the
books are thick they're dirty I've read
them all but I've also listened to the
audiobook it's a breeze it's a joy
they've got like this atmospheric
environmental voice acting it will
transport you to another world and if I
mean the books give you a whole new
perspective on the story like I love the
show but the books you know what they
say about the books here's something
interesting game of Thrones fact the
show is called Game of Thrones but the
actual series if you didn't know is
called Song of Ice and Fire Game of
Thrones is the name of the first book of
the series
oh so this show chose to go into
different time rights that was just the
name of the first book the the series
itself is actually called Song of Ice
and Fire
I think Game of Thrones is better I
actually did though I actually did -
well scheme of Thrones is a little more
limited in scope I think the first book
is a very games of Thrones book and it's
not always the Game of Thrones thing so
I understand the Song of Ice and Fire
although it took a long [ __ ] time to
get to the Ice and Fire part so I get
both of them anyway thank you so much to
audible supporting us if you guys want
support the show go to audible.com slash
a tree podcast get a free audiobook with
a 30 day free trial and finally we have
Casper the mattress company Casper they
told me to sing that they gave me that
idiot
they're like hit a c-note drop it down
to the d7 Casper we got a Casper
mattress it's a it's it's incredibly
comfortable yeah and I'm actually using
their pillow - the pillow is incredibly
comfortable the Casper mattress is
really cool yet they deliver to you in a
box
you bring it out it puffs up because
they really compress it down and when
you open
it up you get surprised by how much it
opens up and fluffs up and then you
can't redo the way it came what like if
you were thinking maybe if I move I
could no it's cuz we tried what about
once you only fluff out one yeah it's a
serious fluff out
you can't deep fluff sar did you try it
you cannot deep flow they're engineers
are obsessive about making the most
comfortable mattresses on earth and I'll
tell you what I compared it to sleeping
on a very comfortable mattress mm-hmm
can you imagine what that's like you
don't have to strain your imagination I
think for the value it's probably one of
the best matches you can get if you're
in the market highly highly highly
recommend it and here's the deal
mattress comes delivered to your door in
a compact box free shipping and returns
available in US Canada and now in the UK
and this is really cool you get a
hundred day trial period considering we
spend one third of our lives on a
mattress it's so important to try truly
sleep on a mattress before committing
that's why Casper gives you a 100 nights
to try it out very cool mm-hmm so if you
head on over to Casper comm slash h3 you
get $50 off your first purchase of a
mattress cool
that's Casper calm slash h3 with promo
code h3 terms and conditions apply I
don't know what they are they just told
me to say that dad why are you doing
that that's weird
something keeps happening I'm getting
frickin hair blasted this trim is not
hearing it I hope no I think it's just I
I really hope that someone with
headphones didn't just get deafened for
life so if you're in the market for a
great new toothbrush a great new
mattress or a wonderful entertaining
audiobook cuz they do hear it consider
supporting the show by heading on over
to one of our sponsors thank you so much
to them guys I'm gonna take a quick
break to urinate and when we come back
we are going to get real with your boys
Skippy and Ryan John Smith I am
super excited so do not go away we'll be
back after a brief brief break thank you
guys so much see you soon all right
welcome everybody back to the h3 podcast
live welcome back
yeah we have got Skippy the now 39 year
old virgin on deck to receive some sage
advice from the ultimate pickup master
Ryan John Smith's they're both legends
Ryan is someone we've spoke about in the
past he's a Soper he's a party animal
he's a musician and most importantly
he's a pickup artist and he's [ __ ]
like 200 girls I do want to ask him
what's the current number now Skippy was
the subject of one of these shows on my
TLC or one of these networks that will
make a show about anything called the
Virgin Diaries and it catalogued his
attempt to just get his dick wet
essentially he's a 34 year old Mormon
and he's never had sex he lives with his
mom in the basement but he's asked
wonderful character who was just so
desperate to dick hit put his dick into
any hole which is admirable something I
really relate to on a personal level I
don't know if he would agree with that I
don't think I asked him yeah and anyway
he's now 39 since that came out and
still a virgin so I want to bring him on
ask him a couple questions and then
we'll get Ryan on the phone to hopefully
coach these two guys and and and ideally
to build this into a more fruitful
relationship between the two of them so
with that being said I Skippy if you're
there I have one question for you to
begin my first question for you is like
when watching that that episode
featuring you on the Virgin Diaries I
noticed that you had a mason jar full of
belly button lint next to your bed that
you brought out during your date can you
explain what the [ __ ] is with the belly
button lint collection okay super quick
story about that 20 years ago when I was
on my Mormon mission everyday we were
supposed to like write in our journals
write and read the scriptures and things
and I was like I don't do I'm like what
do I do every single day and I was like
okay I shower and I'm like
but I also like empty my belly button
when I'm like okay I can't commit to
writing my journal every day but I will
do that and so I just started pulling
out and I there was a little girl from
Christmas that I had and so I'm like
I'll just put it in there something
about being in a Christmas jar makes it
just saying something something about
putting in a Christmas tree okay once
all right go ahead I'm just going to
stop clearly is a little bit of a delay
yeah good between then and when with it
like ten people on the planet knew about
it like my best friend since high school
had no idea that I had it like literally
no one knew about it they came billing
and we're like what's that oh but you
had it laying out clearly if they were
able to see it well it was in my room
yeah yeah but like prior to them filming
it no one knew about it and they're like
oh we're including back I get it yes
everything's fair game but it's not like
I went advertising and selling rate that
they had to go me and my amazing belly
button and color something like I ever
brought a girl on a date that hey want
to see this there's something really
just the fact that it's in a Christmas
style candy canes
you ever smell it you ever put your nose
in there and just take a deep snow that
well your belly button holds like a
[ __ ] wet soggy
in your stomach with sweat and like lint
anyway let's get off that how do you get
so much it's okay that was the part of
the video that stuck out to me the most
he was inquiring how do you get that
much lint well I get lint my belly
button - it's something about being a
fat sweaty hairy guy talking about
myself here I don't mean to say that
about you we die here I think it's
something about the here no you're not
you're maybe the only person that puts
it in a jar every day though and
collects so let everyone know let
everybody know now the offers on the
table for the right offer Skippy will
sell you that jar is there a minimum
what's yeah what what's the minimum
you're looking for probably what $2,500
something like that like if a person
gave me $1,000 right now only because I
think that I could probably get 25
special there's a special promotion
going now for our listeners get a hold
of skip me if you want to buy his belly
button lint collection alright let's get
into the let's get a little deeper than
this as much as I do love talking about
cabone then what did you think in the
first saw her video morning I check my
Twitter and I was at like 1200 and I had
gone from like Virgin Diaries came out
my like 800 Twitter followers up like
1500 and I was super excited about that
but then over the last couple of years
about 1,500 dwindled down and I build it
back up to 1200 and that was Thursday
morning at like 10 o'clock and then
Thursday afternoon at 3 o'clock my time
you guys released the video and within
an hour I was up to because you guys
then released the video and did the
podcast and I was up to from 1200 up
like 1,500 mi
20300 yeah boy and also I had not been
recognized in Utah I have been on a game
show on one money there I had even it
did an internship for a local TV station
in the morning where I was on fairly
regularly and I'm only in the last ten
years been recognized three or four
times and in the last two weeks I've
been time Wow so you seem pretty happy
about it at Wendy oh that's cool man I'm
happy to hear yeah so you're not
considering suing us right not that you
know being on Virgin Diaries was
something that was really fun and I got
to I was supposed to be on the view but
my plane got stranded in Detroit so I
didn't get to go on the view let me ask
you beyond dr. drew to promote it and
then I got to fly up to Seattle and
introduce the Lumineers on stage in
front of the deck the hall ball it
sounds like you have a very illustrious
history I want to ask you something have
you been on any dates lately ago I took
a date to the party like seven eight
years and so we go on dates and like
I've told her a million times like if
she's ever interested in a relationship
I'm there for her so ACCE is she a
Mormon so as I understand it your
biggest your 48th year coming up on 40
years of not never having had sex is the
biggest obstacle in your way the fact
that you can't have sex until you're
married because you're religious Mormon
or at this point are you just ready to
get your dick wet until after I get
married and hopefully it's with a girl
that thank you but at the same time I
don't think the thing what is
when I was 22 like I'm Pro Medical
Marijuana pro gay marriage so I'm not
like like I'm a liberal Mormon and so
what is it I'm gonna marry a virgin like
when I was 20 yeah I thought I was gonna
get married to a virgin
and I'm 39 do I think I'm getting good
so no I'm warning you want to marry a
virgin I got married your dream is to
marry a virgin tell me once once you get
married 20 when once you get married
once you get married what is the first
sexual act that you that you would like
to perform six of them on the way no
time you can't wait you get it out you
get it down you know what to do like you
know where the hole is right it's always
just it always surprising because it's a
little lower than you expect I hear that
it's frequently that it's like it's
lower than you expect you're gonna do it
really quick in the limo and then when
you get to the hotel room what happens
then well because I'm not going to rape
my wife you're not going to take the
lead on this one you're gonna be more
submissive you're more secure into being
submissive having a plan that like okay
so sweetie I've been all I know the song
that I want to do to and it's all coming
back to me now and just when I was 17 I
thought that was the songs I should lose
my virginity to and so it's just been my
go-to Raptor Celine Dion let her take
let her take you there I'm curious
what's the furthest you've ever gotten
with a girl so far and a half a second
and a half base is that Bob of Apple
logo there
well above our
so it was it was both experiencing above
stuff right it's never been I've never a
girls never gone below the waist with
her mouth with me right with hand so
you're allowed are you allowed to get a
[ __ ]
okay thought no talk to the bishop I
love that phrase but so I mean what is
it willing for you to get your like get
a [ __ ] and then just be like well
this is worth discussion with my bishop
[Laughter]
you know like hands are moving in a car
and then it's like oh crap my bishop
about this later right when the whole
intention was if I wouldn't be great if
I got it this at the end of the day yes
so you can I've had chances where I
could have had sex with a girl like
where I've been on dates with Phillip
and I know if I had wanted it to guess
at that point but I really did turn into
speed Carell on the 40 year old virgin
and the next thing you know like you've
accidentally kissed a girl on the face
it really don't worry the whole religion
thing it seems like so rough man such a
rough rough thing to deal with in terms
of sex but I'm hoping that with the
advice of a dating expert like Ryan
Jones miss can help bring your game to
the next level so that we can find you
the girl of your dreams and so that you
can finally move on to that third fourth
and dare I say fifth will a Kay a
homerun Grand Slam I want to take you
all the way with Ryan's help do you
think you would benefit from the from
the dating from the advice of a dating
coach
ya know where I see the most value of
being is like if I ever want to get to
the point where a girl would actually
want to marry me I have to be better
with girls
to just like get them to go that's the
problem is getting that fourth date oh
[ __ ]
I did add to call but it hung up on
Skippy know what I'm trying to get them
both on a call I'll [ __ ] all right hold
on I'm trying to get them in a group
call ad call what am I doing wrong you
call Skippy and then you go hey Skippy
I'm trying to add Ryan to the call hold
on one sec so we're getting Ryan on the
phone our discord have completely failed
how do I cuz when I call him it just
hangs up on Skippy I don't get that you
can cut this part Dan oh here you go
merge okay good uh hello is everybody
there hello Ryan are you there I am here
thank you guys for your patience and
trying to get this up is their first
time doing something like this in our
our basic are our planned method
completely failed so we're on the phone
here with Ryan John's miss the dating
expert with Skippy the 39 year old
virgin Ryan Ryan is a is a god I mean
Ryan how many women have you slept with
you're good no not all good so a my
question my question for you Ryan is how
does your dick stay on how does your
dick not just withered and fallen off
your body after the afternoon that's
like you're throwing your the dice on
the craps table 207 times
well I definitely recommend practicing
safe sex at first at first when you're
with a new partner right we move into a
let's say a trusting monogamous
relationship God and that's good advice
so Ryan let me introduce you to Skippy
who's also on the phone
Ryan what basically wait yeah why don't
you guys why don't you pick it up Ryan
to talk to Skippy did you end up in a
relationship with a few actually I mean
living in Las Vegas it's it's an
interesting game out here you know as a
single guy it's it's uh I enjoy sex with
beautiful women and it's fun to go out
and meet women and well let's focus on
helping scorpy out here Skippy is
basically having trouble getting to the
fourth date he has a lot of dates he
finds a lot of dates but he has trouble
securing the relationship right so what
kind of advice would you give somebody
like see like talk to Skippy like tell
him what does he need to do to get that
fourth day a few thoughts sure well
let's start with some what's what's
going on like if I was dealing with a
dating coaching client first I would
want to find out what are the underlying
issues I'm gonna ask you personally why
do you think that you're not being able
to be successful with women I think the
number one thing is that I I feel like a
failure in my life that I'm 39 develop
and in mom's basement so I think that
that's like I'd be the best thing like
when I was in my 20s and I look like
caring about my future cause like
everyone in their young twenties is
expected to be like this and it was like
yeah go on fun for first
they sell the time that kind of thing
but I know that the reason why it in my
30s it's different is because like even
if I had the right first pick up line
for girls there's that thought that goes
oh well this went really well
and I even wanted to say like hey let's
get out here and go make out someplace
my back home valuation is mom's basement
yeah I saw the video you need that video
six years ago right yeah and you're
still in the same place
yeah I'm pathetic I feel like you're
accepting a way too easy Skippy that
you're like yeah I'm pathetic that's it
it's like you got to get out there and
shake your dick bite there like that's
like the first thing off the top of your
head like I'm pathetic it's like
accepting defeat you're lying believe
that that's where you're at and you're
at that plateau right if you think about
me I'm trying to I don't
I'm not happy with this in fact I my mom
and I even made an agreement that I have
to find a place to live by the end of
September so like I'm forcing myself to
move on and I was like gone and gotten
to help with getting my resume updated
and things to be able to get a better
job and I realized that that is a part
of it right but that also isn't like the
reason why on tinder I'm not getting for
those so I think that's one of the
things that have brought you into this
to know right you know well Skippy do
you feel comfortable with your approach
beginning do you feel comfortable
approaching women do you think you have
a good approach No so what are we gonna
do about that Ryan give this guy some
slick tips on how to [ __ ] get his
dick what
well the problem here Ethan well I think
about his in-game even if he goes up and
and he's approaching girls and doing
well he has no way to seal the deal or
I'm understanding that you're Mormon and
you're not trying to like : uncle a
sealed deal until you're married but you
still have no way to isolate the girl
and her saying right until you end about
your mom's place and you had her own
place yeah that seems yeah you have to
look at the bigger picture so to speak
sure you know you got a yes you have to
figure out how you're gonna get from
from point A to point B and whether
that's true whether you're not trying to
actually have sex with the girl and you
want to end up this this whole issues
kind of woman does want a man who's
gonna [ __ ] her
like not you know well that's
interesting let's follow that thought
because Skippy I was asking about what
he fantasized his first you know sexual
position would be on his future wife and
he said like he's not trying to rape his
girl and he's just going with the flow
so I'm getting some like very submissive
vibes from Skippy have a history of like
knowing what the first thing to do even
if I got to that point was so he's good
at Famous sergeant Ryan is that enough
yeah I don't think that's gonna be
enough we're gonna have to step up your
game Skippy since you made this this
video like six years ago
I'm gonna ask you a question if you
continue this pattern that you're on and
you keep doing the same things that
you've been doing the past six years and
you keep doing this the rest of your
life what kind of results do you think
that you're gonna end up with what do
you think is gonna be the outcome I
completely agree with you I think that
you're right like I need to make like I
need a head-to-toe makeover give me a
makeover baby what are you talking until
or physical Skippy I want admit I want
to give your ass a makeover I want Ryan
to give you a makeover I love it and
Ryan to the mall I'm gonna need you to
put them in the chokers and [ __ ] and
capes where other guys is like okay the
end game is to have sex right if we just
bar and say like okay he's waiting till
it gets very bad but we put gold that's
not just like getting sleepy to the
point where he can have sex but getting
sleepy to the point where she can end a
first date and get a second date for
sure or even have a Goldie to get Skippy
to go on a date where do you think I
make out at the end of the first date
and then get a second date to go with it
that's a much better goal for me than go
have sex kind of thing you know and
feels like brother guys yeah they're
hobos go out get laid Ryan let me let me
ask my self in here yeah Ryan what give
me up give me you as your dating expert
a pickup artist a motivational coach
let's lay out a plan a playbook for
Skippy yeah yeah we've got to change
like the way that he's thinking about
this first know like when you're we're
saying like this is a goal to like get a
make out like it's not hard to make out
with a girl like girls like to be kissed
just as much as girls
and you're making it you've got to take
the [ __ ] off the pedestal like saying
and it's so out of reach but you have to
understand like your man and it's
building you to take what you want
Danny be a dominant real man Oh keep
going right I would
oh [ __ ] are you kidding me are you guys
there okay you're there you're that go
ahead right I got you back
wait are you there Skippy I'm here
Oh what happened to Ryan oh you are
there okay so go ahead you yeah yeah you
I left off at take what you are cuz
you're a real man and that and so I was
no I was like I was a feeling that so
continue on that thread I mean you've
been doing this well not just the six
years but you've been doing this like
almost 40 years now like if you if you
keep doing what you've always done
you're gonna continue to keep getting
the results that you've always got does
that make sense sure yeah we need to
change these B hat these patterns of
behavior that you have right we need to
imagine imagine like your mind is like a
computer like and right now you have and
like you're not even like Windows 7 like
a like Windows 90 wipe out that old hard
drive and reinstall I know
Ethan hates windows but skippy 2.0 we
need to continue right so I'm just I'm
just trying you know we're gonna have to
get together and brainstorm on this need
to get together you know what do we do
what do you think we're gonna get mo of
makeover head to toe I think we need
he's got to look good to feel the hair
what are we gonna do about the belly
button lint collection should he bring
better or what do we do about that
hey Skippy hold on hold on Skippy I know
I know I know
Skippy hold on hold on let me talk here
I know that you don't bring it on dates
but the mere existence of it is a
[ __ ] huge deterrent like I try to
sell it I'll give you a week to sell
that Skippy if there's someone out there
who's weird enough to wonder on that but
I'm telling you if we're I mean I just
don't think that that is something you
can carry around because when you're in
an intimate conversation we need to
share the fact that you have a belly
button like collection next year better
yeah yeah I'll do that I'll autograph it
Skippy but if nobody buys it you got to
get rid of it because that's just a
skeleton in the closet when you bring me
up there and we meet I'll bring it with
completely ready you sell whatever you
get the highest bid and I can bid on it
right so that I can I think you maybe
overvaluing this thing somebody I think
if somebody takes it for free you're
getting a good value
okay so we're gonna sell it you have you
have one week to sell it or we're gonna
do it too
[Applause]
they are you saving down you saving the
stones though it was the thing thanks
for all that time so I have it somewhere
but it's not like it's late memories or
was it like
like pictures I have pictures just
because I it must have brought you
immense pain but yeah if you're trying
to attract women like having stuff like
that in your face don't feel that
they're gonna kind of feel something
cringe in the pit of their stomach where
with me to my place Skippy we're talking
about so we're talking about Skippy 2.0
right I think the same part of you that
has this desire to collect bellybutton
lint and kidney stones is the same part
of you maybe that's making a difference
and we want we want to see the grown man
Skippy the new verb of you okay so let's
let's let's focus this then it's okay to
let some of these parts of you go and
decide like you're in a safe place you
know it's gonna be a good thing yeah
yeah absolutely I mean look my end goal
is to just you know you know let's put
let's let's get that day so here's what
I'm proposing and the coming weeks I
want to bring both of you guys out here
to LA I want to bring Ryan Jones miss
and Skippy the 39 year old virgin out I
propose that me and Ryan do give you a
look of a makeover okay we're gonna do
some pretty woman yeah I'm a pretty
woman the hell out here okay bring bring
up the kidney stones end up and the
belly button lint with because we need
to we need to figure out what to do with
that stuff okay and we're basically
going to coach you mentally physically
it's going to be like dating boot camp
and ultimately what I'd like to do
because Ryan specializes in infield
training so I want to put you in the
field
with Ryan and basically put a earpiece
in your ear and I want Ryan to be giving
you real-time advice on how to
be securing these relationships that
sound like something we were doing that
it was kind of like a joke but I do not
take a student who has not trained with
me like one-on-one in a classroom
environment and just put the earpiece
into him and take him out it's it's it's
more like after like maybe three or four
or five sessions right through the
earpiece thing right he doesn't really
need that but I think right now we need
to give him a makeover and then he needs
to start learning how to approach women
like a confident man and be able to
express what he wants you know I want
you to be able to I want you to be able
to be comfortable with with your desires
as a man I want you to be able to do you
know well right now you know when he's
seducing women and being able to go up
to them and tell them exactly what you
want you know I want you to be able to
like really like hi let's get out of
here and no I think we're all on the
same thing yeah like famous like George
Clooney or something like that would he
use a line like that not talk to the
bishop he would no no what do you know I
don't you seem try hard I want you to be
able to just walk up to a woman and be
like hey you know I saw you from from
across the way I just thought you were
super cute and I want to come meet you
I'm Skippy you know maybe Skippy a real
no he's so comfortable and basically all
right so anyway this is the plan and I
and also the earpiece part we're going
to do that - sure okay okay it's
invisible it's invisible yeah and then
fine and then I have one more question
for you Skippy if I bring in a pastor
certified to marriage and I find a bunch
a beautiful woman and when you get to
choose the one that you love you go on a
date she's great
would you be willing to come in here and
get married to somebody no my my
long-term happiness
and the Internet are probably not going
to be the way that I find what I want
well I'm just thinking like we could
just take a shortcut like we could take
a shortcut like you bring in a couple of
cuties okay so it's not worth it to
bring in a couple of cuties to seal it
up have someone get married you know get
the dick wet talk to the bishop and then
when I go on dates with girls I really
hope it ends with like making it autumn
that that girl wants to do that again
and I realized that one day that weeks
is a boy that's another thing you're
looking at this in a very a way that's
very Hollywood and it's not practical in
a real life application in a real life
situation when you're meeting a woman
getting properly at the end of the day
maybe it could be though maybe it could
be passionately who's going to sleep
and off their feet man Skippy alright
guys let me let me cut you off there I
think well I think we're at a good place
I think we're at a good place
yeah it's gonna be smooth it's gonna be
slick so I'm looking forward to
arranging you guys both to come out here
and Skippy we are gonna transform you we
are going to build you make you better
stronger and ultimately you're going to
be talking to the pastor or the bishop I
mean we'll be talking to the bishop
alright guys well thank you so much to
Ryan Jones miss Ryan do you want to know
where can people find you YouTube my
name's miss and and Skippy where can
people find you at here for me so I'm
doing a vlog and let's gonna find that
Twitter on Twitter at I am Skippy and I
got my current YouTube channel if I am
Skippy but yeah Instagram I am Skippy
Twitter I am Skippy you know what's
gonna happen when you actually you know
you're gonna have to change the name of
your YouTube channel hopefully by the
end of this next couple weekends alright
guys okay good I'm glad you've thought
about it okay good
guys thank you so much I'm gonna thank
you guys guys thank you so much I
appreciate you I'm gonna get in touch
with you guys in the next couple in of
the weeks and thank you all both you
guys so much for coming to join us was a
lot of fun I appreciate you both thank
you thanks dude Thank You Ryan
cool
all right I think they have a lot to
talk about to talk about I think we need
to get those guys in a room together
yeah a glass of of Henny I want to get
big and drink any mm-hmm it's
challenging because Skippy's got this
religious aspect to it
yeah by Ed and is just looking to find
the one which is what a lot of people
are yeah but also at the same time I
think that if it seems like talking to
the bishops a good trade it's like you
[ __ ] up you talk to the bishop
it's like watching you get your hands
dirty you wash them you're good you talk
more complicated than that
you only get three talked to the bishops
in a lifetime before God hits you with
the lightning bolt well that was [ __ ]
interesting look we're out here we're
trying new things give us a break
these guys are both interesting I'm
gonna see what kind of yeah it was
interesting to hear them I mean hey so
thank you everybody for watching this
week the HT podcast
stay tuned next week we have somebody
scheduled who we have scheduled is it
Jenna and Julian I think so I think it
is jenna Marbles and Julian we do need
to confirm with them that it's the final
I think it's the first so that is going
to be exciting would be the Friday show
I wish you guys an awesome excellent
weekend I'm excited for my weekend we're
going to celebrate yep we're going to
Las Vegas with our friend post Malone my
best friend everybody's giving me [ __ ]
for that he's I said he's one of my best
friends and doesn't matter he's one of
my best friend he's a close friend of my
he's a friend okay
tone it down a guy I know we're going to
Vegas with them we're gonna watch the
fight we're gonna play blackjack we're
gonna drink some beer I'm very excited
so I hope you guys have a great weekend
thanks for sharing your Friday with us
or it's Thursday actually yo appreciate
you all and have a Oh should we take a
call I think I already wrapped it up
yeah we only ended up every time on call
on Tuesday
we'll be taking more calls wait okay
yeah we don't have we don't have anybody
in standby okay well hey we took one
call it was great so that's a fun thing
guys see you next time
Tata
[Music]